[Musik]
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
[Musik]
ihr habt gerade die thüringerin silvia
vita gehört eine große schlanke frau in
ihren 50ern ihre glatten blonden haare
fallen ihr ins gesicht ihre strahlenden
blauen augen zeigen entschlossenheit die
frau hat schon früher einen schweren
verlust durchleben müssen denn ihre
geliebte schwester carmen klemm wird vor
über 30 jahren grausam vergewaltigt und
ermordet eine lange zeit ist seitdem
vergangen doch auch die
staatsanwaltschaft erfurt hofft immer
noch auf einen durchbruch mord verjährt
nicht dh
eine straftat nach paragraf 211
strafgesetzbuch kann immer aufgeklärt
werden solange der beschuldigte noch
lebt wem fällt die junge kamen damals
zum opfer wer ist seit jahrzehnten der
hauptverdächtige der aber nie gefasst
worden ist wie lebt eine schwester über
die hälfte ihres lebens lang mit einem
solchen verlust mein name ist sky dumont
und ich begrüße euch zu einer neuen
ausgabe von tatort deutschland einem
cold case einem bisher unaufgeklärten
mordfall was geschah mit carmen klement
[Musik]
deutschland im juli 1989 es ist der
letzte sommer der ddr die leute sind
aufgebracht fliehen über ungarn oder die
tschechoslowakei aus dem osten nach
westdeutschland proteste auf den straßen
der wille nach freiheit brodelt so
explosiv in der luft wie nie zuvor kurz
vor dem fall der mauer ereignet sich in
der ddr ein schockierender mordfall
die gerade einmal 22 jährige
krankenschwester carmen klemm wird am 6
juli hinter einer turnhalle im
thüringischen sömmerda aufgefunden nur
wenige hundert meter von ihrem
elternhaus entfernt auch die bild
zeitung berichtet seit damals regelmäßig
über den mord im sommer 89 wurde unsere
schwester ermordet wer kennt den killer
meiner schwester warum konnte carmen
keller noch nicht gefunden werden eine
junge blonde frau mit einem damals wie
auch heute wieder modischen ponys über
den wachen augen sie ist ein glückliches
mädchen am anfang ihres
erwachsenenlebens und hat noch viel vor
bei der arbeit im krankenhaus blüht sie
auch sie will sogar studieren und selbst
ärztin werden doch das schicksal hat
andere pläne für sie denn ihr wird nach
einer unbedeutenden disconacht das leben
genommen
bild reporter karsten care des zuständig
für die bild in thüringen und verfolgt
die ermittlungen seit jahren das
aufgeschlagene notizbuch ist voller
alter notizen zu dem mordfall der
journalisten stützt das kinn mit dem
weißen dreitagebart auf die geballte
faust in all den jahren versuchten die
ermittler immer wieder ihr bestes doch
erfolglos nicht fasziniert besonders an
dieser geschichte die schwester von
carmen klinsi hat ein letztes
versprechen ihren eltern gegeben ich
werde den täter finden
carmen schwester silvia witwe lebt noch
immer in sömmerda und kümmert sich
aufopfernd um das grab ihrer schwester
carmen und ihrer mittlerweile ebenfalls
verstorbenen eltern der friedhof ist
fußläufig von silvias zuhause entfernt
hierhin hat sie kamen extra umbetten
lassen bild-reporter care trifft silvia
die frische lilien für ihre schwester
gekauft hat und neben ihrem lächelnden
foto auf dem grabstein platziert was
bedeutet dass das quartier aus schwester
jetzt unmittelbar neben irgendwo im haus
zu haben
für jeder tag und nachtzeit
hierher gehen und
mich um die kraft wege kümmern denn das
ist mir sehr wichtig das ist immer
morgen bis auf strache meinte kratzen
trinken ein radler wenig feierabend
hause und unterhalte mich antreiben was
musst du am park über erlebt hat holte
sachen schlechte sachen über mich
geärgert hat dass nur
und haben sie dann auch das gefühl ich
sei noch dazu
kamen silvia trennen nur zehn monate
deshalb wachsen sie quasi wie zwilling
auf
sylvia schenk dem reporter ein lächeln
während sie von ihrer schwester erzählt
doch ihre trauer lässt sich kaum
verbergen
ein besonderer mensch nichts weiteres
passiert ist sondern die haben dies kann
jeden gemacht worden die hatte
wunderschön
der hat alles gestimmt ich habe
aber ich bin hier angekommen einsam
silva will nach über drei jahrzehnten
und endlich gerechtigkeit um mehr über
die rechtliche lage zu erfahren stattet
reporter care dem oberstaatsanwalt
hannes grünseisen einen besuch ab diese
führt den journalisten in sein
verglastes büro in erfurt von dem aus
man fast schon einen panorama ausblick
über die landeshauptstadt hat anhand
eines straßennetz plans der kreisstadt
sommer dar erklärt grünseisen wo das
verbrechen in der besagten nacht
stattgefunden hat herr grinsen was
können sie uns erzählen über diese nacht
vom ersten und zweiten juli 1989 in der
carmen klingen ihren letzten weg
genommen hat wo ging der genauen
geschädigte befand sich in der nacht in
der mitternachts disco im jugendclubhaus
in sömmerda seinerzeit hat dort getanzt
und hat gegen 31 mit einer freundin die
diskothek dann verlassen und ging dann
hier entlang
zusammen mit der freundin
dort bei der bahnhofstraße trennten sich
die beiden jungen frauen
zurück im jahr 1989 ganze 25 kilometer
trennen die wohnung von kamenz freundin
von ihrem elternhaus
oberstaatsanwalt grünseisen fährt mit
dem finger auf der karte entlang kamen
geht diesen langen weg mitten in der
nacht ganz allein und trifft dort
irgendwo auf ihren mörder
die genauen details wird die polizei
nicht preisgeben fakt ist jedoch vor
ihrer ermordung wird carmen vergewaltigt
kassen care läuft mit schwester silvia
die straßen ihres ehemaligen
wohnviertels in sumatra ab eine ruhige
gegend in der überwiegend familien
wohnen an der stelle vor ihrem damaligen
elternhaus bleiben sie stehen hier steht
mittlerweile ein wohnblock silvia
erinnert sich genau an den tag der tat
der bild reporter versucht mit ihr zu
rekapitulieren wie die familie überhaupt
von dem vorfall erfahren hat hier stand
früher
als die dann aus ihrem urlaub
zurückkehren
und
die haben
[Musik]
carmen ist zu diesem zeitpunkt jedoch
bereits tot erst vier tage später wird
ihre leiche von einem anwohner in einem
gebüsch gefunden und das unmittelbar
gegenüber von kamenz elternhaus tage
lang liegt das mädchen dort hitze regen
und ungeziefer ausgesetzt als sie
endlich gefunden wird ist sie kaum
wieder zu erkennen ein fürchterlicher
anblick
kamen schwester silvia kämpft mit den
tränen während sie sich an den bisher
wohl schlimmsten tag ihres lebens
erinnert ich habe nur gesehen dass
[Musik]
wir sie nicht durch ein kokon sollten
sehr heiß es war regen
und da kommen sich ein bild machen wie
es ausgesehen hat vier tage hat sie hier
bei der witterung draußen geblieben das
war wie
ein stich ins herz
als dieser todesnachricht kam von ihrer
schwester
wie ging es für ihre eltern weiter ja
meine mutter sich über nacht eis
geworden
gth sie war über nacht über nacht die
war die waren anders davor
vorher
120 ermittler sind kurz nach dem
leichenfund an dem fall dran zunächst
geht man davon aus dass es sich bei dem
täter um einen der vielen
schichtarbeiter nahegelegene betriebe
handelt die auch nachts unterwegs sind
doch plötzlich zieht auch einer von
kamenz damaligen nachbarn die
aufmerksamkeit auf sich bild reporter
carsten k bild von oberstaatsanwalt
hannes grünseisen wissen wie es dazu
gekommen ist wir sind ihnen die
ermittler damals auf die spur gekommen
dass richtiges gab seinerzeit einen
beschuldigten
der hatte sich nach auffinden der leiche
verdächtig verhalten hatte dort
gegenüber eingesetzten
volkspolizisten
täterwissen offenbart also wissen
offenbart was man eigentlich nicht haben
kann wenn man an der tat nicht beteiligt
war wurde daraufhin auf vorläufig
festgenommen weil er fand sich fünf
monate seiner zeit in untersuchungshaft
der verdächtige wollte es wohnt damals
genau gegenüber von kamenz elternhaus er
macht sich negativ bemerkbar
als er die junge kamen beim sonnen mit
einem fernglas beobachtet auch die
schwester silvia witwe erinnert sich an
die anschuldigungen gegenüber holger ist
erkannt hat aufgrund dessen weil er mit
uns zwar schulspeisung gegangen ist
und daher kann ich ihn und als ich das
bild gesehen habe
dann kam
eine lehrer seine leere im kopf so
absinken so ein
ganz komisches gefühl als wir also die
innere eingebung hat sofort gesagt ja
das könnte ja sein ein nachbar der die
junge kamen schon kennt ein mann zu dem
sie vielleicht auch ein gewisses
vertrauen hat hegt holger es insgeheim
gefühle für carmen oder ist es gar eine
krankhafte besessenheit steht er mit der
vergewaltigung seiner begierde und
bringt das mädchen schließlich aus
verzweiflung schließlich kennt die junge
frau ihn trotz des verdachts wurde
holger es bis heute nicht als täter
überführt
oberstaatsanwalt hannes grünseisen
erklärt weshalb es gab 32 vernehmungen
fast 270 stunden vernommen worden und
keiner einzigen dieser vernehmung hat er
irgend eine tatbeteiligung eingeräumt
oder konnten irgendwelche objektiven
beweise dann dingfest gemacht werden so
dass am ende das verfahren eingestellt
wurde weil kein hinreichender
tatverdacht bestand der fall ereignet
sich im jahr 1989 die mittel und wege
der wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen
verbessern sich bis heute stetig
fortschrittliche methoden die ein klein
wenig hoffnung geben es sind ja auch
spermaspuren gefunden worden aber auch
mit den jetzigen untersuchungsmethoden
konnten diese nicht soweit
individualisiert werden dass man sie
einer konkreten person zuordnen könnte
aber die wissenschaft verbessert sich
ständig und man darf in so einem fall
die hoffnung nie aufgeben dass der fall
dennoch auch anhand der jetzt noch
vorhandenen spuren extrakte beweist
werden könnte doch es bleibt die frage
wer hat der erst 22 jährigen auf so
schreckliche weise das leben genommen
war es holger es am ende doch nicht auch
carsten care kann nur vermutungen
anstellen wir wissen nicht was ich
damals genau hier abgespielt hat hat sie
zum beispiel einen liebhaber
zurückgewiesen oder gibt es einen ganz
anderen verdächtigen denen die polizei
noch gar nicht auf dem schirm hat allen
hinweisen wurde nachgegangen alle
ermittlungen eingestellt der mord von
carmen kleben wird zu einem cold case
für carmen schwester silvia ist der
kampf um gerechtigkeit jedoch noch lange
nicht vorbei sie hat jahrelang gespart
und eine belohnung von 10.000 euro für
jeden zum täter führen den hinweis
ausgesetzt obwohl sie als obst und
gemüse verkäuferin nicht viel geld
verdient würde silvia alles dafür geben
um endlich frieden zu finden für ihre
familie und für sich
sie sollen immer das gefühl haben wir
kleben noch irgendwo wir geben nicht auf
ich gebe nicht auf ich will das nicht zu
sprechen kommen um zu betteln habe ich
erfüllt ich habe meine eltern gepflegt
bis zum lebensende
[Musik]
und da hoffe ich dass ich das schaffe
alle die an dem fall beteiligt waren die
ermittelt und gekämpft haben setzen auf
hinweise der bevölkerung
auf eure hinweise bleibt bis zum schluss
dran es gibt noch wichtige informationen
bis zum nächsten mal sky dumont
am ersten juli 1989 besuchte die junge
krankenschwester kamen klehm eine party
im jugendclub dem heutigen volkshaus
sömmerda in der weißenseer straße 33
gegen mitternacht macht sie sich mit
einer freundin auf den weg nach hause
ihre wege trennen sich in der
bahnhofstraße am krankenhaus kamen ist
von da an allein unterwegs
erst vier tage später am 6 juli wird
ihre leiche im gebüsch hinter einer
turnhalle gefunden
dabei war sie nur wenige hundert meter
von ihrem elternhaus entfernt der
nachbar holger es wird als
hauptverdächtiger ermittelt aber aus
mangel an beweisen wieder freigelassen
sollten sie hinweise haben die den
ermittlern in irgendeiner weise nützlich
sein könnten wenden sie sich bitte an
die polizei oder die staatsanwaltschaft
erfurt
helfen sie silvia ihr letztes
versprechen einlösen zu können
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone der bank
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
nadja goldhammer redaktion bild carsten
k stefan effenberg
obwohl ich weiß worauf du hinaus bist
auf sex oder sagen wir man hätte du
saufen sex in der öffentlichkeit was
wird da aufgerufen das siebzehnte
bundesland der mallorca podcast mit ingo
wohlfeil und stefan netzeband wie fühlt
sich der ballermann in der neuen saison
was kosten aktuell flüge und hotels
welche promis sind auf der insel und
welche stars den bierkönig oder mega
park mit das siebzehnte bundesland bist
du immer auf dem laufenden
jeden donnerstag wo es gute podcast gibt
[Musik]